welcome back to minute made park this is
game two of the doubleheader between the
angels and
astros astros taking the first game six
to three over the angels
brandon belak is on the mound for the
houston astros that start went last time
form got roughed up in an inning a third
throwing 28 pitches and giving up seven
earned runs
wait here's the situation the angels
have them loaded two outs need a hit now
from brian goodwin
rounds that one through on the right
side and that's going to be an rbi
hit the angels will get one on it and
the ball gets away from reddick and
rolls all the way out to the wall
out there and the angels are gonna get
three on it as ending up at third base
is goodwin
what a break right there you figured the
angels were gonna get two they end up
getting
three and the angels have a three
nothing lead
so the batter now is joe adele slice
down the right field line a fair ball
that will bring home goodwin joe's gonna
head to second base
rbi double makes it four nothing joe
adele just got his first rbi of his
major league career
uh double with two outs and the angels
have a four nothing lead
adele at second boom boom at first luis
fernando the battery and randhifa lines
us to left field tucker racing over
toward the line headlong dive did he
catch it yes he did
what a catch by kyle tucker diving along
the line on the ball
that was slicing away from him and that
ends the inning wow fourth start first
time ever pitching against the astros
fastball 88-91 will throw a slider
curveball and a change-up and that will
be the
second out there's one chopped on the
right side nice stop there by wistella
flips to tehran
and julio has a clean bottom of the
first it ends on a 3-1 ground out
kyle tucker stands in for the astros
tucker pulls this one right to
rendezvous they turn into a double play
nothing guriel could do this ball is
absolutely smoked but rent heapo
the angels had that shift on on the
right side even having radepo
closer to first base than normal so two
outs and nobody on for carlos correa
the left side fletcher with a diving
stop gets up and got him
that was robbery by fletcher to his left
and
getting that scalding one hopper could
be first and second with two outs
ground ball towards the middle diving
stop out two bay the throw will be
in time what a play by jose
altuve what a play by jose altuve
as he dove in the grass got up on one
knee
and a one hopper to guriel in first base
luis
renifo their ninth place hitter biting
for the second time he's over two
he swings at the first pitch and drives
his ball deep down the left side and
that ball is out of here randhifo
connects right there that is his first
home run of the season his first
rbi of the season and that was a no
doubter
angels add on it's five nothing first
pitch fastball swing and ran hippo as
you mentioned this ball as soon as it
leaves the bat it is
gone finally for ren heapo he just
squares this one
up and this is what we've heard from joe
madden all year long is how strong that
renthifo is and what
you see is batting practice how he's
able to drive the ball
finally able to square one up in a game
there's some movement going on in the
angels bullpup but nobody warming up as
of yet julio tiran has got 44 pitches so
far two strikeouts
no walks one hit allowed and with two
quick outs the batter will be michael
brantley
here's the next pitch on its way and
it's another fly ball that mike trout is
camping under he'll make the grab on
that one and
clean ending for tehran who's done a
real nice job here
so far in the spa game that was just a
nine
pitch inning the angels are going to
have runners at the corners
this is lifted in the air hit into left
center field chasing over making the
grab on that one is tucker tagging will
be ohtani it's plenty deep enough for
him to
easily come in and score so goody gets
another rbi in the squad game is third
and the angels increase the lead it's
now six nothing so the leadoff man on
for kyle tucker lined him to a double
play his last time
and that's cranked out to right center
field that's going to get down
and go all the way to the wall julie
around third he will score
kyle tucker he's on his way to third
base and he picks up
his fifth triple of the year this one
drives in julie
and it is six to one angels the one out
of tucker still the third for reddick
who struck out or who uh flight out his
first time
redick lifts this down the left field
line racing over is
good win and he makes the catch and then
bangs into the wall
the throw home as tucker tries to score
and he slides in
safely then boom couldn't handle the
throw and it is
six to two in favor of the angels it's
now a 6-2 angels lead
burrow struck out his first time up that
ball hit the other way hit pretty well
looking up brian goodwin this ball's
gone
abraham toro hits an opposite field home
run
and the astros have cut the lead in half
this sitting it's now
six to three two and two the count now
to straw
up the middle this ball is gonna head to
the outfield garno being waved around
trout comes up throwing garneau will be
safe it's a six-four game
straw with an rbi single the astros back
within two
angels leave the asteroids six to four
crucial period of the game runners on
the corners nobody out
reaching forward as the bouncer best
guriel that'll bring home a run trout's
going to turn and head to third
with stella rbi single seven for halos
at the plate is david fletcher
and that's a little flare it's going to
fall into right field and that's going
to be a base hit trout will score
on that one and david fletcher comes
through
back-to-back rbi hits allowed by blake
taylor
and the angel lead goes to 8-4
that'll bring up shohei ohtani and that
one is
a delayed called third strike and shohei
is out looking that'll be the first out
von drak
the whole plane up here just tossed joe
madden this ball is
down and away to ohtani this ball is not
even close
and certainly for joe matany
he's not gonna be around to see the rest
of this ball game now they're loaded
with
one out here in the seventh up by an
eight-four scorer
and he swings at that one and chops it
deep in the hole it's short correa's
throw to first will be laid a run will
score
the bases are still loaded fletcher gets
an rbi single his
third hit in this fall game here's
shohei batting and the pitch is low it
gets away from the catcher garno
and coming in and scoring from third
will be mike trout everybody moves up
the base
and now the angels have a 10-4 lead
shohei lines went into right center
field a base hit
bostillo will score fletcher is going to
be waved around he's going to score
shohei on his way to second
he's in there with a two rbi double 12
to four halos
so the batter now their lead off man all
day long miles straw he grounds one to
third nice stop there by fletcher throws
them out so the angels
end up litting this double header